merci d'être là merci d'être aussi
nombreux à nous suivre merci que
tournera gauche des poteaux s'ils
veulent savoir si bien sûr vous
reconnaissez bien sûr celle à exciser
porte d'auteuil colle à ses heures
perdues c'est vrai mais on est la
priorité à droite et pour les chiens et
que je pense tout de suite à mon oreille
au premier regard par les joueurs pour
ça donc je dis que je pense que vous
voulez non je dis cela qu'ils avaient
deux couples qui était parti en voyage
de noces pour un s'est très bien passé
pour le c'est un peu plus compliqué
regardez-moi ça au fond reloaded joachim
löw voyage de noces au maroc était très
chaud à l'extérieur mais encore plus
chaud dans la chambre qui n'a encore et
encore encore rapproché je savais que
physiquement et tout se passe bien mais
là je crois que c'est encore mieux que
ce que j'aurais pu imaginer
on peut féliciter yoakim alors que le
pauvre mathieu c'est même pas sûr qu'il
puisse approcher sa femme à moins de 7
mètres
un petit pépin deux oui c'est gentil
mais ma maison pour les prochains jours
tu peux dormir là aussi alors maroc est
tellement d'amour qu'on a l'impression
d'être dans titanic au début du film
cette relation c'est tout ce qu'on peut
avoir les deux est juste magique
incroyable vie comme dans un conte de
fées c'est beau c'est
tessa alors qu'à chiffres il ya
tellement d'amour il n'y a pas d'amour
en fait qu'on a un passé devant titanic
mais alors fin du film dans ses bras
quand il a vraiment un geste comme ça je
suis toujours un peu de tension mise à
jour son petit séjour ce voyage aux
noceurs tous les cadeaux
peut-être se noyer
et
ça fait la belle
elle est sympathique et s'arrêtent chez
le palais sympathique un effort de le
dire ça oui
gilabert il faut déjouer ses dires il
aurait dit non non non non il faut voir
après un moment quand tu joues le
mariage je sais mais bon là scénario
premier regard c'est un jeu mais ils
n'ont rien vu et il paraît qu'ils
peuvent divorcer très vite non il avait
trois semaines après après leur période
d'essai où ils cohabitent comment
viennent le voir là il confirme où ils
vont exactement comme le noviciat où on
dit maintenant je quitte au jeu reste
dans l'église elles confirment leurs
voeux mais là c'est pareil [ __ ] bolat
en ce cas par les militants non mais oui
tiens ça avait dit mariage croissance
est dramatiquement ben ouais ça ça m'a
servi pour amener l'objet enfin la
personne de john mari qui vient conte de
fées c'est delphine la plus classe le
golfe
delph elle découvre la vie de son mari
rome en camargue et la chance car homme
sait que pour faire rêver d'elle fils a
pas besoin de l'emmener aux maldives
pour manger dans un trois étoiles non
d'elf qui l'emmène au flunch de
sucy-en-brie ses plus beaux jours de
fête
[Musique]
moi quand
on n'est jamais venue de carla sa
présence enfants mon travail comme ça
alors avant aucun mec n'avait été
chercher delphine à son boulot mais bon
j'imagine que l'adage une science et qui
lui a fait la cuisine au moins une fois
un homme qui fait la cuisine monnaies -
varrault dire mais je connais pas ça
même plus se désole encore une fois
alors avant aucun mail avec l'usiné pour
delphine mais bon j'imagine que
l'adjoint fiancée qui lui a déjà offert
une brosse à dents et
j'avais pas bon faire de brosses à dents
tel film mais j'imagine qu'elle a vu un
fiancé qui l'a emmené en week-end au
moins une fois quand même mais en fait
tu t'amènes au portugal
pendant trois jours le week-end mais bon
j'imagine qu'elle a déjà été plein de
fois chez s'est fiancé quand même jamais
fait elle est comme ça chez chimie
gobain dont conclusions sur de bien
compris on n'est jamais mon travail je
connais pas ça non plus j'avais personne
moi j'avais d abroger camion l'a fait
sans jamais vous fait aller comme ça
[Applaudissements]
d'aplomb
non merci
elle est folle de romain voulait
développer lui pourrait conseiller
naguim ce que lui les champions de vache
est justement dans le sud-ouest pour
voir les bombes à bien toutes ces aides
comme en parler c'est une potée les
daytona avec ça c'est une pote et les
bourgs étant alors romain justement au
moins des racheteurs c'est ça veut dire
qu'il fait des courses camarguaises à
rennes face à des toros en herbe parce
que je le donne elle est bourrée
d'accord alpin et koroma c'est le justin
bieber de camargue situe l'écoutant vous
fait il pas sortir dans la rue sans que
des meufs le jette des strings sur la
tête c'est vrai que c'est pas facile
quand on est convoité par plein femmes
cyril vous connaissez mais le problème
ou progressent compassion de faire
découvrir toutes ces passions à sa femme
c'est surtout la chimio là où je
expérience avec 50 ans ils ont qu'elle
était là uniquement parce que c'était
romain leur hauteur des cercles à cette
heure-ci notoriété en nature
on a tiré les filles étant ce qu'elles
sont là juste parfaite
il est obligé de répéter ad le fil
combien c'est difficile d'être une star
en camargue entre tom cruise et brad
pitt et j'étais là parce que c'était un
bosseur
quand tu es radoteur voilà trophée des
as la star locale
r je me suis procuré une photo de romain
ce week-end qui rencontrait tous ses
fans venus du monde entier
delphine batho romain mais comme c'est
une star locale d'el finale a du mal à
croire ce qu'il lui dit tiens
sa fille
même si romain ne peut pas aller faire
ses courses en trois gardes du corps ça
reste un grand romantique c'est trop
le petit cadran je trouve au japon
mais il est trop mignon promet des sur
l'écran ça c'est le summum du romantisme
le problème c'est qu'il ya des copains
de romain qui sont amusés à pirater
l'écran et ce qu'ils écrivent c'est
beaucoup moins romantique fait encore
avancer la relation et
et voilà prêt mais lyon c'est votre
sinon est papa 14 ans donc il a été
primé de jeunesse m'a bien sûr mais ça
vous aime beaucoup ce couple moi j'aime
bien aussi j'espère que ça va durer ça
mignon les deux autres elle est sur dix
logements ils sont pas mal oui c'est
long c'est simple physiquement ça c'est
plutôt elle mon style de céline joli
coussin
ah ouais super qu'il prendra ces non
juste un gars n'est attendue je vais te
dire tu préfères l'abricot à la banane
on s'en fout mais c'est vrai non mais
attends c'est pas grave alors chaque
soin de lui on adore bien sûr chaque
soir en tout cas depuis hier vous fait
un petit résumé de l'émission dont vous
pas vous appelle parce que cinq ans ce
grand jeu du monde en tout cas les
appels 50 secondes insights un petit
résumé de mariée au premier regard
hier soir mario premier regard auraient
dû être interdits aux moins de 18 ans
doucement
[Musique]
c'est
alors c'est pas du tout ce que vous
croyez en fait c'est encore elodie lieu
à khimki son show quand ils vont
n'importe quelle activité
c'est chaud c'est honteux
[Musique]
on retrouve ma copine delphine pourrait
de la maison de romain c'est encore plus
beau que le château de versailles
c'est très beau j'adore ces bosses et
j'adore j'adore tous s'engagent
c'est trop mignon
c'est mon idole il a la classe même
quand il se cure le nez une posture de
conduite bien à lui en romains il veut
clamer son amour partout pour sa femme
et lui sûr que ça intéresse tout le
monde regardez vous voulez vous dire le
cabinet se marier qu'on était superbe à
découvrir
merci
[Applaudissements]
à